[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Arnaud Benedetti comme tous les
vendredis bonjour Arnaud merci d'être là
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire et Catherine tricot
bonjour Catherine merci d'être là
directrice de la revue regard on va
parler avec vous de la France insoumise
dans la tourmente
notamment à cause de l'affaire alors
est-ce une affaire on en parlera sopia
Chikirou il y avait un complément
d'enquête qui lui était dédié hier soir
sur France 2 alors est-ce que ça va
provoquer des tensions à la France
insoumise d'autant qu'il y a déjà des
fractures à la nuple socialiste ont voté
hier soir pour une liste autonome aux
européennes on parle de tout ça dans
quelques instants et Quentin on va
également parler du Conseil national de
la refondation sur les émeutes vous
étiez à matinon vous hier exactement
voilà une rencontre avec des élus
au total membres du gouvernement plus la
première ministre et effectivement
qu'est-ce qui en est sorti c'est ce
qu'on va voir ensemble et d'abord on
regarde l'actualité dans nos
[Musique]
régions l'actualité dans nos région du
côté de Limoge où on retrouve
anneesophie pédgè bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes rédactrice en
chef adjointe du populaire du centre et
à lire dans vos pages et c'est votre une
d'ailleurs un dossier sur les
difficultés dans les épades
oui tout à fait c'est bonjour à vous
toutes et à vous tous c'est c'est assez
problématique en te vienne j'aiécouté
avec attention agès Busin à l'instant
sur les les prises de conscience en
matière de santé et chez nous c'est en
matière de vieillissement euh qu'il faut
prendre qu'il va falloir prendre
conscience de de de l'urgence d'agir
pour les épades en fait chez nous en
Hute viienne les épades sont
essentiellement des établissements
publics et ils sont avec que pour
différentes causes l'inflation les
charges les faibles compensations de de
l'État ils sont en grande difficulté
financière pour la
plupart donc voilà c'est c'est un cri
d'alarme qui est qui est lancé par deux
ou trois établissements et cette
conséquence de de de l'alourdissement de
toutes ces charges c'est derrière une
augmentation du coût pour pour le
patient et les familles qui va devenir
très
problématique le coût du des des lit a
atteint ce ce ce ce cette année 2023
2000 € ça devient un coûp un coup très
très lourd pour les familles sachant que
il n'y a un/art de des familles qui qui
relèvent de de l'aide
sociale Sophie certains établissements
parviennent à tirer leur épingle du jeu
alors effectivement si si tout le si
beaucoup
d'établissements cri cri cri CR au
secours en fait euh il était
évidemment exclu de fermer ces
établissements ils vont s'endetter des
fermetures se sont sont sont sont
toujours menacées c'était le cas
effectivement à à la courtine près près
d'uson c'est un tout petit établissement
de d'une quarantaine de de places qui
fonctionne très très bien les
soignants ils sont visiblement ils
travaillent dans de bonnes conditions
les patients ils sont ils sont sont très
bien aussi euh mais euh l'établissement
est petit et il était menacé de
fermeture euh les patients devaient
aller sur des sur des établissements de
Buson qui étaient encore moins
bien moins bien dotés donc
l'établissement va va va continuer de de
de fonctionner comme ça mais je pense
qu'il va falloir penser
euh à long terme sur sur l'accueil de
des patients parce qu'aujourd'hui rien
n'est vraiment pensé là on est face à un
coup qui augmente mais derrière euh il y
a pas vraiment de solution de
d'hébergement de il y a quelques
nouveaux établissements comme comme près
de Limoge au palais survienne mais voilà
les projets sont encore trop peu
nombreux pour accueillir tout toutes les
personnes âgées qui vont arriver
malheureusement dans ces établissements
merci Anne Sophie merci beaucoup c'est
la une du populaire du centre et votre
dossier vous l'avez dit les épades dans
le rouge c'est à lire aujourd'hui dans
votre journal merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous on va passer au débat de ce
club on va parler des émeutes en tout
cas du diagnostic du gouvernement post
émeut Quentin hier ellisabeth borne
réunissait un conseil national de la
réfondation sur les émeutes qui ont
touché le pays avant l'été comment ça
s'est passé qu'est-ce qui s'est joué à
matigon hier effectivement c'était un
conseil national de la refondation pour
poser un diagnostic et des pistes de
réflexion 3 mois après la mort de Naël
et les émeutes des violences qui ont
touché des villes et aussi des banlieux
fin du mois de juin début du mois de
juillet il y avait au total ministres
qui étaient réunis avec Elisabeth borne
pour ce CNR comme on dit comité national
Conseil national de la refondation dont
Gérald Darmanin pour l'intérieur Éric
Dupont moriti pour la justice face à eux
une vingtaine d'élus locaux de maires
confrontés à ces violences on a vu par
exemple hier Vincent jeambbrin le maire
de la rose mais aussi il y avait autour
de la table des chercheurs des
universitaires ou encore des
représentants du monde associé la
réunion était organisée autour de quatre
thèmes le profil des émetiers tout
d'abord ensuite la prévention de la
délinquence également le soutien aux
familles et dernier thème la justice des
mineurs et la responsabilité parentale
une nouvelle concertation donc et aucune
prise de parole hier lors de cet
événement qu'une prise de parole
publique devant la presse quel était le
concret de cette réunion écoutez à la
sortie un responsable
associatif c'était moins des pistes que
un vrai dialogue entre les les
associations les élus beaucoup de maires
et les ministres pour qu'ils entendent
aussi les remontées du terrain et qu'
soi mieux sensibilisé à ce qui se passe
très concrètement au niveau des familles
au niveau des villes au niveau de
l'éducation et ce qui s'est passé pour
ces émeutes et certains élus c'est à moi
de leur côté certains élus s impatient
et se demande si l'exécutif n'est pas en
pleine improvisation exactement la
réunion d'hier a été organisée à la
vavite en quelques jours en 48 he même
les élus de banlieu notamment craignent
le manque d'ambition d'Emmanuel Macron
pour les quartiers dit politiques de la
ville mais l'exécutif la sû la séquence
va bien déboucher sur des annonces
fortes écoutez un élu local encore une
fois à la sortie de matinon hier soir je
crois qu'il y aura dans les propositions
immanquablement une territorialisation
des politiques publiques c'està-dire on
voit bien que les Mair les présidents
d'aglot le bloc communal les
départements sont appelés pour faire en
sorte soit sur les contrats locaux de
sécurité soit dans l'appui à la
parentalité soit dans les politiques
publiques que nous portons de plus en
plus on sent bien que le gouvernement a
envie de s'appuyer sur les territoires
et ça je crois que c'est une bonne chose
les annonces qui devrai intervenir à la
fin du mois d'octobre mais le champ des
sujets est très vaste on l'a vu car
au-delà de la question des collectivités
locales que l'on vient d'entendre il y a
le les sujets police justice soutien au
tissu associatif mais aussi comment
aider les parents parfois dépasser ou
encore mieux former les familles au
dérive des réseaux sociaux Catherine
c'est une bonne méthode ce conseil
national de la refondation de réunir
tout le monde autour de la table pour
faire le diagnosti de ces éme 3 mois
après oui je trouve ça pas mal d'avoir
en effet des acteurs des associatifs des
intellectuels des chercheurs des
responsable de politique publique donc
ça ça me paraît une bonne une bonne
chose je trouve que c'est un peu tard 3
mois après pour faire un diagnostic
quand même on aurait peut-être pu
accélérer un tout petit peu mais surtout
ce qui me paraît quand même assez
étonnant c'est que les quatre thèmes que
vous nous avez donné comme étant ceux
qui ont structuré la discussion et le
diagnostic renvoie tous à des questions
individuelles c'està-dire à des
responsabilités individuelles la
délinquence la famille les réseaux
sociaux et cetera c'està-dire des choses
qui relèvent de l'action de chacun or ce
qui s'est passé n'est pas une action
individuelle les gens enfin je veux dire
quand ça a pris une telle proportion
c'est qu'il y a un problème qui est un
problème politique et global enfin
global je ne dis pas qu'il est général
je dis pas que toute la France était en
émeute mais néanmoins il sait pas c'est
quelque chose qui signale une question
qui n'est pas que de l'ordre de quelques
individus qui auraient malagi et je
trouve que c'est quand même une entrée
euh qui laisse pas pas par le bon bout
ça euh oui puis surtout pas pas au
niveau de la question c'estàdire on peut
pas simplement prendre la question par
le profil des émetiers et la
responsabilité des parents c'est quand
même pas de ça dont il s'agit il il dit
il se dit quelque chose de plus profond
de plus structurant euh dans les
quartiers qui se sont et dans la
jeunesse et des quartiers qui se sont
révoltés cet été ARN ben moi je si vous
voulez c'est déjà le cadre le conseil
nationale de la refondation d'une
certaine manière c'est aussi pour
l'exécutif le moyen de faire vivre une
structure adoc qui a quand même du mal
malgré tout à se développer et ou qui a
suscité beaucoup de scepticisme donc on
se saisit de la question des émeutes
pour l'intégrer dans une structure qui
de fait en effet pose question sur le
fond ensuite moi ce qui me frappe dans
l'agend enfin dans l'ordre du jour c'est
que c'est pas tant la responsabilité
individuelle même si en effet je veux
dire elle est mise en avant par cette
par cet ordre du jour c'est que c'est un
agenda qui est excess enfin
exclusivement régalien en l'occurrence
c'est c'est pas tellement la dimension
sociale du sujet qui est traité que la
dimension régalienne donc quelque part
on voit bien qu'on a là-dessus un
exécutif qui envoie un signal politique
qui consiste à considérer que ce
problème est d'abord un problème
essentiellement régalien un problème de
sécurité un problème de d'ordre publque
un problème de justice et cetera et
cetera donc c'est quand même quelque
part un message politique qui est envoyé
aussi à travers cet à travers cet ordre
du jour le troisème sujet c'est
évidemment au-delà des intellectuels des
chercheurs c'est la relation avec les
territoires et la relation avec les
maires c'est-à-dire que on sait très
bien quand même que euh Emmanuel Macron
est un président de la République qui a
quelques sujets avec le local et qui va
là en l'occurrence essayer de renouer un
lien avec des mairres pour essayer de
trouver et construire comme on dit un
certain nombre de solutions ensuite le
4e point c'est que c'est vrai que ça
arrive assez tard c'est-à-dire que ces
émeutes ont eu lieu fin juin début
juillet on est au début de l'automne il
y a quelque part si vous voulez un un un
défaut au moins à l'allumage qui est est
quelque part assez surprenant au regarde
quand même des événements que nous avons
connu au mois de juillet dernier
Catherine sur le calendrier et peut-être
aussi sur la question avec les maires he
parce qu'effectivement ça fait partie
des points oui alors ça je je suis
d'accord avec vous que ça veut compenser
un défaut de relation avec les maires
qui n'ont pas très bien pris le fait que
parallèlement est été annulé la Réunion
qui était de comité interministériel des
villes qui était prévu la semaine
prochaine et qui vient d'être annulé au
dernier moment donc il y a quand même
une gestion des relations qui est un peu
cavalières on les convoque 48 heur avant
pour venir ici on leur annule la Réunion
qui était prévu depuis longue de plus
longue date et elle réunira sa00 mè à la
fin du mois pour faire ses annonces il a
pas eu d'annonce voilà donc voilà il y a
pas eu d'annonce et cette partie de de
discussion préalable n'a pas lieu ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point c'est que en effet je pense que la
question defin ça ça rejoint ce que vous
venez de dire c'est que là on a parlé du
régalien dans lequel les maires en fait
ont pas tellement de place c'est c'est
pas vraiment eux qui gèrent la question
du rapport à la police à la justice et
cetera donc d'une certaine manière on
les fait venir pour parler d'autres
choses que de leur problème de leur
territoire de la la manière d'intégrer
ces quartiers dans la vie commune et la
vie de tous donc il y a une espèce de
yatus qui qui enfin on comprend pas très
bien peut-être que ça a à voir avec
l'improvisation non mais on réunit des
gens puis on sait pas très bien sur quoi
on va les réunir mais on les réunit
quand même oui le le le Conseil national
de la refondation effectivement ça avait
été lancé l'année dernière c'était
encore un éè une 1è étape he dans ce que
vous voulait le président de la
République après le grand débat pour
voilà créer du consensus et cetera mais
effectivement un an plus tard ça n'a pas
pris beaucoup l'ont boudé on se souvient
des des parlementaires notamment au
Sénat qui était très critique voyez pas
très bien quel était le cadre
institutionnel de ce de ce qu'il
appelait même un un machin et là on a
l'impression qu'effectivement on essaie
de faire vivre la marque Conseil
national de la refondation en
estampillant une réunion à Matignon de
de de de ce CNR de ce de ce titre
effectivement comme si on voulait faire
vivre un objet politique qui n'a
toujours pas pris et qu'on essaie de de
relancer de force ou elle tient le
président République je pense que les
élus auront eu en tête le fait qu'il y a
eu un conseil national de la refondation
qui a fonctionné c'est celui sur le
logement et en fait il il a fonctionné
il a travaillé et toutes les
propositions qui ont été faites n'ont
pas été on été écartées donc là il y a
quelque chose qui est en effet comme ça
à voir avec le problème des émeutés et
je pense que la question du logement a
aussi à voir avec ce qui s'est passé
c'est quand même très
malheureux un mot quand même parce que
on parlait évidemment de ce qui s'est
passé hier mais il va bien falloir des
réponses politiques derrière une fois
que les annonces auront eu lieu est-ce
qu'un consensus politique peut se faire
sur un tel sujet Arnaud il peut
peut-être se faire euh du côté du local
c'est-à-dire des élus des maires qui
sont confrontés quel que soit leur
étiquette au mêm problèm et qui doivent
y répondre rapidement donc je pense que
de ce côté-là il peut y avoir en effet
la production d'un d'un compromis après
c'est plus difficile concernant
évidemment les rapports de force
partisans et les rapports de force
parlementaires aujourd'hui où on n' pas
intérêt du côté des oppositions non plus
quelle que soit la gravité du problème à
faire la courte échelle à Emmanuel
Macron sur beaucoup de sujets d'ailleurs
pas seulement sur celui-là donc mais
est-ce que sur les thèmes choisis va pas
y avoir aussi une réactivation du
clivage droite gauche c'est évident sur
la question en effet aujourd'hui
s'agit-il d'abord d'un problème de
sécurité ou d'un problème culturel comme
une partie de la droite le considère ou
s'agit-il plutôt d'un problème social
d'un problème d'aménagement comme le
pense ou d'un problème d'égalité comme
le pense une par parti de la gauche on
voit très bien que ce sujet est un sujet
qui en soit est extrêmement clivant et
finalement reproduit les fractures
politiques de la société politique
française donc en effet vous avez
j'allais dire presque structurellement
là une difficulté à pouvoir produire du
consensus pour pouvoir produire du
compromis mais encore une fois l'acteur
local de ce point de vue là est un
acteur extrêmement important et c'est
plutôt en effet habile de la part de
l'exécutif là en l'occurrence de
travailler avec les acteurs locaux en en
2002 si vous vous souvenez la réponse de
Jacques Chirac
à la montée du Front national et à la
qualification de Jean-Marie Le Pen ça a
été de créer l'enrue avec Jean-Louis
borlot Jacques Chirac qui étaitagence
nationale de rénovation urbane
absolument qui était quand même un
président de droite sans aucun doute et
il réussit quand même autour de l'Agence
nationale de rénovation urbaine avec des
difficultés au démarrage mais en fait a
créé un certain consensus et on a vu la
réaction qui a été celle de Jacques
shirac en 2005 après les les émeutes
urbaines de 2005 qu' il a su trouver des
mots pour parler à la jeune
qui s'était révolté et pour leur dire
vous faites partie de la société
française vous faisêtes nos enfants de
les enfants de la République c'était ces
mots et ce qui est étrange che
qu'Emmanuel Macron qui a été élu pour
être de gauche et de droite n'a
absolument pas trouvé su parler d' il
n'a pas parlé et ensuite il n'a pas
trouvé les mots pour parler au aux gens
et là enfin aux gens aux jeunes pardon
et là il en fait il fait une entrée qui
est strictement régalienne qui est
vraiment pas du tout sur les deux pieds
c'est-à-dire pas du tout sur le côté
urbain sur le côté égalité mais
simplement sur le côté on va vous va
vous remettre dans le bon rail combien
même vous auriez des choses à nous
reprocher oui vous avez raison de faire
cette comparaison sauf que la différence
entre 2002 2005 c'est que Infiné le
baricentre j'allais dire de de la vie
politique française et même de l'opinion
publique française c'est quand même
considérablement déplacé vers la droite
ce qui explique aussi d'une certaine
façon aujourd'hui j'allais dire le
lexique et la sémantique d'Emmanuel
Macron de donc je crois que ça c'est un
facteur qui me paraît essentiel et
ensuite quand même force de constater
que bien en rue tout ça c'est c'est
formidable mais la réalité c'est que un
les problèmes demeur les problèmes sur
le terrain et les émeutes on sont
l'expression et deux ça n'a pas permis
de faire reculer d' Yota bien au
contraire le rassemblement le Front
national devenu rassemblement national
donc quelque part il faut aussi quand
même tirer les enseignements d'une
situation qui d'une certaine façon
traduit une forme d'échec en un mot ce
que je pense c'est que en effet il
s'agit pas simplement de prolonger l'en
rue et de l'amplifier il y a des
questions nouvelles qui sont apparues
comme celles des inégalités
territoriales des services publics de
l'école et deuxième point sur ce que
vous dites qui est tout à fait exact le
Baris centre politique s'est déplacé
c'est quand même un tout petit peu de la
responsabilité de l'exécutif de de
l'avoir accompagné voir poussé dans
cette direction il aurait pu jouer quand
même un tout petit peu plus en Shirak
est à droite et il réussit à à
équilibrer les choses Emmanuel Macron se
faitirer de droite et de gauche et ça
termine complètement à droite on va
parler de la gauche et de la FR soumise
très bien avant de terminer hier soir
France un numéro de complément d'enquête
sur les agissements de sopia Chikirou
une proche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sous la
menace d'une éventuelle mise en examen
pour escroquerie aggravé son
comportement est également pointé du
doigt on va écouter ce qu'on disait hier
manuel bonpard il était notre invité le
coordinateur de la France insoumise
depuis 5 ans il y a rien de nouveau
aucune nouvelle information le journal
Le Monde dit il y aurait sans doute
peut-être une mise en examen je sais pas
comment ils le savent parce que en tout
cas aucun d'entre nous qui avons été mis
en cause dans cette affaire n'a été
informé de ça il n'y a eu aucune
surfacturation sont dans cette campagne
la campagne de on parle de la campagne
de J Mélenchon de 2017 hein pour que les
les gens qui nous écoutent comprennent
cette campagne est celle qui a coûté la
moins cher de ce de l'ensemble des
candidats je ne conteste pas son rôle et
ses pratiques ça a été une une
une vous n'avez jamais entendu ça vous
êtes coordinateur du parti ça a été un
maillon très important de des campagnes
présidentielles parce que j'ai bien
compris avec beaucoup de sexisme
d'ailleurs qu'on essae de dénoncer comme
on l'a fait à mathil Panau comme on l'a
fait à à Rachel KK voilà il ramène ça
sur la question du sexisme em manuel
bonpard qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
réaction de la France insoumise à à
cette affaire je la crois significative
du problème en fait c'estàd qu'il y a
plein de questions dans l'affaire
Chikirou il y a des questions
financières il y a des questions de
comportement de de de de sopia Chikirou
mais il y a aussi la question de sa
place dans le dispositif pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle a cette place aussi central et
je crois que ce qui englobe le tout et
qui est le plus problématique c'est le
caractère je veux dire le fait que ça
fasse corps et que on ne parle pas et et
en fait alors on peut dire d'une
certaine manière c'est quelque chose qui
est fréquent dans les groupe humain de
vouloir faire corps et mais là c'est
érigé en en en en théorie politique
c'estàd que là il faut faire corps il y
a la loyauté face aux camarades et face
au groupes parce que au bout du compte
c'est la révolution citoyenne qui est en
jeu c'està-d qu'il y a toujours un enjeu
supérieur et donc on exige de tous
l'alignement le silence ou la solidarité
avec des
pratiques les plus audacieux disent si
les faits sont avérés mais ils en
connaissent une partie de ces faits je
veux dire ils n'ont pas tous à être
avéré les listes de diffusion dans
lesqueles sopia Chikirou intervient avec
la violence avec lequelle elle
intervient le le le comportement qu'elle
a au quotidien le fait qu'elle soit
montée en première ligne comme ça pour
défendre catenin c'était aux yeux et au
sud de tous donc ce n'est pas simplement
des questions financières qui ça en
effet peuvent relever d'une enquête et à
laquelle tout le monde n'a pas accès
mais par contre la place le comportement
de sopia Chikirou et le fait que ce soit
toléré et plus que toléré cou ouvert
accepté par la direction de la France
insoumise je pense que là c'est un
problème politique c'est un problème de
culture politique qui est délétaire non
c'est un problème de culture politique
indéiablement c'est-à-dire que on voit
bien que la réaction des très proches de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est une réaction de
solidarité sans faille et il s'agit de
dire circuler il n'y a rien à voir il y
a un phénomène qui est un phénomène de
bande presque qui est qui qui exprime
cette réaction ensuite ce qu'il faut
noter c'est que
on a d'autres voix qui aujourd'hui au
sein de la France très pr de jeanl
Mélenchon mais il y a les autres
commence je veux dire à quand même
exprimer un certain nombre de réserves
et un certain nombre de critiques et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est pas tout à
fait nouveau parce que des conflits au
sein de la France insoumis il y en a eu
et parfois sur des lignes politiques
après 2017 il y a un certain nombre de
militants de la France insoumise qui ont
quitté la France insoumise considérant
que finalement l'option prise par
Jean-Luc mélenchan était une option qui
conduisait à une impasse politique et
qui n'était pas conforme finalement à
leur propre à leur propres valeur mais
là si vous voulez la le problème c'est
que c'est toujours le même c'est la même
difficulté c'est le décalage entre les
déclarations d'intention l'affirmation
des valeurs et les comportements
personnels et c'est vrai que c'est
ravageur sur le plan de la perception de
l'opinion publique ça ne fait que
creuser si vous voulez ce fossé qui est
déjà très grand entre une grande partie
de l'opinion publique et sa classe
politique surtout dans un parti qui
considère que finalement il fait de
j'allais dire presque la préoccupation
morale jeis dire l'impératif catégorique
de son de son de son de son combat et en
plus on parle alors moi j'aime pas du
tout parler des des des affaires qui
sont en cours parce que d'abord c'est
toujours trop compliqué il s'agit pas de
faire le procès de qui que ce soit mais
en plus on parle de financement et donc
quand on parle de financement c'est
quand même un vrai sujet en terme de de
relation à la morale de relation à
l'éthique oui tout à fait mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que là aujourd'hui ce
qui est rabageur c'est l'écart entre la
la préconisation d'une révolution
citoyenne du 6e république et un mode de
gestion de la France insoumise qui de
façon très clair et théorisé notamment
par Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est pas un
mouvement démocratique et avec des
pratiques qui sont des pratiques
coercitives et qui interdit le débat et
c'est ça qui est pas enfin je veux dire
qui est vraiment très très choquant pour
pour les militants il y a ce que vous
dites sur la question de l'argent parce
qu'il y en a qui ont donc travaillé
bénévolement où ont été payés au SMIC
pendant que apparemment ça c'est si j'en
crois ce que dit le monde mais c'est à
c'est à prouvé en tout cas qu'ils ont
été payés au SMIC ou qui n ils n'ont pas
été payés ça c'est certain mais le
bénévolat en politique c'est une
question normale enfin je veux dire je
trouve pas ça scandaleux de l'autre côté
mais mais mais il y a pour ça je vous
dis il y a deux questions il y a la
question financière mais il y a aussi la
question de comment vit la France
insoumise et est-ce que ce parti peut
continuer de ne pas avoir de débat quand
éventuellement la gauche et la nupes et
dans la difficulté dans laquelle elle se
trouve on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
rapid débat tjours la France insoumise
par l'exclusion ou le départ et ça c'est
quand même un problème en terme de
culture politique et de relation à la
démocratie c'est vendredi tous les
vendredis on vous emmène à la découverte
de notre patrimoine on va aller en scène
saintnis si le graffiti est un art de la
rue souvent illégal La Courneuve à La
Courneuve une ancienne usine investie
par desgpeurs est désormais ouverte au
public avec l'accord de la mairie Samia
de chir nous fait découvrir la Bab
Coquerie on est sur l'ancienne entrée de
Babcock ce qu'il en reste puisque les
premiers bâtim on été détruit la
première fois qu'armonie artiste
graffeur vient repérer cette usine
désaffectée les lieux sont totalement
fermé au public racheté par des
promoteurs une partie des bâtiments doit
être détruite on est début 2020 et puis
là on entend parler d'une petite fenêtre
cassée d'un petit Axès qui pourrait
donner lieu à une friche immense c'est
le début de la babcoquerie une poignée
d'artistes s'introduit d'abord par les
toits parmi eux Panzer l'auteur de de
cette fresque qui ne montrera pas son
visage le graffiti il a une grande part
de de d'illégal de côté interdit et
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça qu'on est
rentré dans Babcock on avait aucune
autorisation il découvre alors un lieu
hors du commun une ancienne usine de 4
hectar en partie classé au patrimoine
industriel remarquable des h voûé du 19e
siècle en béton armé avec plus de 15 m
de hauteur sous plafond nous on voyait
cet espace comme une nouvelle mine d'or
un peu comme un nouvel espace vierge où
on pourrait y faire quelque chose et on
s'est dit bah pourquoi pas y essayer de
mettre de la diversité et c'est pour ça
qu'on a ouvert un plus grand nombre
d'artistes encore au moins 150 artistes
viendront investir les murs pendant 3
ans un foisonnement artistique qui va
sortir les lieux de la
clandestinité plus besoin de rentrer par
les toits le maire de La Courneuve
accepte de leur confier les clés il faut
dire que son histoire est liée à celle
de l'usine Babcock c'est comme ça qu'il
est arrivé dans la région en 1982
recruté comme dessinateur industriel moi
ce qui m'a décidé c'est que c'est un
lieu de vie historiquement c'est un lieu
de vie il y avait des grafes
historiquement avec des conseils de
sécurité qui étaient peints sur les murs
euh et et donc on est à une autre
période il y a plus d'industrie à
l'intérieur il y a quelque chose qui se
prépare pour aller
vers un lieu socio socioculturel et et
et donc ben dans cette mutation euh que
cette appropriation puisse exister c'est
c'est la vie qui vient le lien entre les
artistes et la mairie c'est Thomasin
zoler qui l'a permis la ville a confié à
cette historienne de l'art spécialiste
du graffiti l'organisation de visite
guidée de la
babcoquerie une forme d'officialisation
assez rare pour un lieu ouvert
illégalement c'est pour moi très
important d'ouvrir ces Liu là au public
ou du moins de les montrer parce que
pour moi ça représente vraiment ce qui
est le graffiti pur et dur c'està-dire
ce qu'on on va retrouver trou ici des
artistes qui ne sont pas dans les
institutions qui vont être boudés par le
marché de l'art parce que souvent par
exemple le marché de l'art va essayer de
vendre forcément des artistes qui sont
déjà côté un terrain de jeu exceptionnel
mais éphémère un tiers des œuvres a déjà
disparu dans les travaux cette triple
Hal la plus vaste accueillera une scène
culturelle harmonie aimerait qu'une
partie des fresques soit conservé mais
la question n'est pas encore tranché un
gra qui traverse le temps c'est rare
c'est beau souvent c'est caché on est
témoins en fait de d'un style qui est
celui de de 2020 de techniques que sont
cell de 2020 de préoccoccupation donc
pour moi c'est en ça que ce serait ce
serait intéressant de de garder ce lieu
et ce serait un bel hommage rendu à à la
culture graffiti qui qui sé invité ici
CER également mais gratuitement aussi la
Bab Coquerie restera ouverte au public
chaque samedi jusque fin octobre si les
œuvres disparaissent ens suite des murs
il en restera tout de même une trace
photographique dans un livre en
préparation que s il dit la très proche
et voilà pour ce reportage de Samia de
chir la semaine prochaine on vous
emmènera au Château de Sedan élu
monument préféré des Français on verra
tout ça d'abord on regarde ce qu' la une
de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Quentin on commence avec
Paris Normandie dans son édition de Ran
le journal raconte les suites de
l'important incendie qui a touché deux
immeubles c'était samedi dernier voilà
une école est en cours de
décontamination les deux immeubles qui
ont brûlé samedi était situé
effectivement à 30 m de cette école que
l'on voit à la Une du journal et ces
bâtiments qui ont brûlé contenaient de
l'amante l'école est est donc fermé au
moins jusqu'à lundi pour des opérations
de nettoyage et des analyses mais pour
l'heure les prélèvements sont rassurants
104 ont été réalisé depuis l'incendie
ils sont tous négatifs il faut dire
aussi que la population reste très
marquée sur place par l'incendie de
l'usine lubzol c'était en septembre 2019
on s'en rappelle des hommes en
combinaison de décontamination a une
d'autres journaux oui c'est une petite
petite bête qui continue à faire parler
compris dans la presse régionale les
punaises de lit qui sont effectivement à
la une de l'actualité le Midi Libre et
le républicain Laurin qui publie ce
matin des cahiers spéciaux le
gouvernement organise d'ailleurs à cette
occasion une réunion aujourd'hui à ce
sujet à Matignon récit dans ces deux
journaux de l'angoisse vécu par les
personnes touchées on parle sport pas
foot cette fois on parle rugby puisque
ce soir on joue contre l'Italie c'est la
Coupe du Monde qualification en quart de
finale en vue voilà ça n'a pas échappé à
la la presse quotidienne régionale de
très nombreux titres reviennent
effectivement ce matin sur le match de
ce soir alors sans Dupon qui se remet de
sa blessure au visage un match capital
pour le 15 la victoire nous qualifie une
défaite nous élimine pas le droit à
l'erreur peut-on lire ainsi à la une du
progrès on termine avec les miss Quentin
oui on sait que vous adorez les miss
arien effectivement en ce moment sont
élus les miss Miss ces régions ou
exactement mais effectivement en ce
moment sont élu les Miss au niveau
l'échelon régional avant la compétition
nationale et donc on voit les portraits
de quelquesunes de ces candidates comme
par exemple Justine et Poma à la Une de
l'Union elle est en 4e année de médecine
à la faculté de reins ce qui fait dire
aux deux journaux que ce sont des Miss à
la tête bien faite et bien pleine qui
veulent casser les codes merci Quentin
vous aussi vous adorez les merci d'avoir
été avec nous regardev une la revue
Politique et parlementaires le savant le
politique et le peuple l'enjeu du siècle
et Catherine la Une de regard climat la
science peut-elle sauver
l'humanité de question elle a une de
regard se rejou
presque que paraî merci beaucoup merci
tous les trois merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi on vous souhaite un très bon
weekend on se retrouve
lundi